A surprising finding from our earlier work is
that spammers can perform behavior on the network
that is extremely uncanny and unlikely to be
performed by a legitimate network user. For example, what
we saw is that the spammer could hijack an IP prefix for a very short period
of time, such as 10 minutes. Send the
spam or potentially multiple spam messages from IP addresses
inside that IP prefix, and at the end of the attack withdraw the prefix. This
allows attackers to use ephemeral IP addresses essentially
rendering IP blacklists ineffective. In fact, we saw
on any given day about 10% of the email senders are from previously unseen IP
addresses. This ephemerality or transience of the IP
addresses of the spam senders makes it particularly
difficult to maintain a blacklist. In fact,
we've found many single-packet features that tended to
work well. In other words, features that
a receiver could make a decision on just
based on the first packet that a
sender sends. Such single-packet features include, the distance
between the sender and the receiver, the density
in IP space in terms of how many
other mail senders are nearby, and the local
time of day at the sender. Other features,
such as the AS of the sender's IP,
also worked well. If we're willing look beyond a
single packet and look at a single message,
the number of recipents, and the length of
the message also prove to be effective in
distinguising spammers from legitimate senders. Finally, we can look
at aggregates. For example, if we're willing
to look at a group of email messages
we can see how message length varies over time or across a group of different
messages. Putting these features together in a
system called SNARE, or Spatio-Temperal Network Level Automated
Reputation Engine achieved a 70% detection rate
for a false positive rate of about one-tenth
of 1%. This level of accuracy is good enough to be
used in practice. It provides comparable performance to state of the art
IP-based blacklists such as Spamhaus. But it only uses network-level features,
thus making it less susceptible to
the ephemeral nature of IP-based blacklisting.